foreign
[Music]
hey you guys welcome back to tomes of
Terror yes I finally read another horror
novel so we're going to talk about it
so Amy cross uh this was a name that I
actually had not encountered before uh
in the realm of horror fiction I guess
but I started doing some research into
her work and um I'm kind of surprised
that I hadn't heard of her before now
because I mean it looks like she's
written a metric [__] ton of books uh
most of them being like Paranormal
horror like ghost stories stuff like
that I think she's written some fantasy
as well uh she's a British writer it
also looks as though she has
um you know I don't know how
interrelated these are but it looks like
she has a couple of different series
like going on at the same time
um and the books seemed to be very well
reviewed and very popular like a lot of
people seem to read them so the
particular book of hers I read
um which as with a lot of the books that
I review for this show I just kind of
chose it at random because it was free
on Kindle unlimited and it had a title
that sort of reminded me of novel
project at least the working title of
the novel project that I've been working
on for the past year or so
um but I don't think this particular
book is part of any of her previous
series you know what I mean I think so
I'm pretty sure it's like a standalone
um so this came out in I think August of
2022 so it's fairly recent
now I have to say right up front that I
had kind of an odd experience with this
book and it's kind of it's going to be
kind of difficult for me to articulate
like what like the weird thing that I
had with this in some ways I almost feel
like I didn't like it
um I mean it's sort of like okay so like
the characters I found to be kind of
thinly drawn and pretty universally
unlikable that's not usually a deal
breaker like I don't think all
characters have to be likable but in
this case I don't know I just found a
lot of them kind of like all of them
pretty much annoying and the story
itself was kind of a little bit
repetitive like especially in the first
two acts but in spite of all that like
having said all that
um I found that I still couldn't stop
reading it and it's like so when I
wasn't reading it and like I was you
know at work or I was like you know kind
of forced to do something else I was
often found myself like kind of like
anxious to get back to it to like see
what was gonna happen so it was like a
really weird I don't know I don't know
if I've ever read another book that had
this kind of because usually it's like
I'm really into it or I'm just like man
I'm not feeling this this one was kind
of like both things at once and it was
like really confusing to me it was like
really really weird like I was I had a
compulsion to like keep reading it but
then I was like I don't know these
people are just like pissing me off and
it's like I don't know what it was um so
yeah so I actually love the premise of
this book
um and the Mystery of it just pulled me
right in like from the first paragraph
So I guess that was enough to get me
like invested in the story even though
the characters like I said kind of
pissed me off and they didn't really
come across to me as relatable or like
real people in any way
um I kind of feel like most of that
maybe was something to do with I don't
know like it maybe it was kind of to do
with like their attitudes of the way
they were but I think too it um was
someone like the dialogue I didn't
really like the dialogue all that much
to me and maybe this is just my
perception of it but it seemed like it
sounded
kind of like um stilted a little bit or
like unrealistic uh sounding
um and I don't know if that's maybe just
like a disconnect between the
particularly British tone of voice
because the author is British and you
know me being American and having like a
different you know Cadence or like a
different way of talking but the thing
about it is I read a lot of British
authors and I don't usually have that
issue so I don't really know if it was
just this particular writing style or
the way that she writes dialogues that
kind of like I don't know it just
sounded very stilted to me I guess so at
the beginning of the story and this book
is called the ghost in room 119 if I
didn't mention it we're actually
following an English couple named Steve
and Penny now they've just become
engaged and they're on like a week's
holiday as they would say over there uh
in Barcelona Americans would say
vacation in case you're not from here so
from a character point of view I feel
like Steve just comes across as just
kind of your stereotypical Bland blah
sort of assholy dude you know what I
mean like he doesn't really have any
quirks or he doesn't like seem
particularly interesting he's just like
a guy you know what I mean so while
they're on this vacation
um he seems to just kind of like yes
dear his way through the whole thing
um also though I have to say he seems to
have and maybe that I could just be this
might be me reading into it but he did
seem to come across as like having a
little bit of like some maybe barely
concealed resentment uh toward his
fiance and maybe toward women in general
I feel like maybe I'm you know I don't
know that was just kind of like the
impression that I got from his character
so his fiance Penny
um she comes across initially like as a
little bit of kind of like a basic [__]
I guess like not not exactly like a
bridezilla because you know what I mean
there she's worried about like you know
the wedding and everything like that but
she's kind of one of those sort of
demanding like high maintenance kind of
chicks that dudes are always you know
kind of complaining about it's like man
she wants this and that and the other
thing and women blah blah so she's kind
of like that she does actually her
character does kind of get better as the
book goes on like she has a little bit
of an arc and she becomes like a little
bit less of like a blah or like a wet
mop or whatever but she's still not
super compelling like as a person like
nobody in this really is um is exactly
at least like the fir the the two people
like at the center of the story are not
like super compelling they're just kind
of like average British people you know
what I mean and there's average middle
class white people and they're just kind
of like kind of boring so um I will say
though that I was actually surprised
like as I was reading this that a woman
had written it because the female
character the two main female characters
in the story like um you know one of
whom is Penny and one of them I'll get
to in a minute but the way the
characters are written it almost kind of
came across as like a male author
writing what he perceived to be oh these
are the two types of women it's like
here's the demanding rigid one that's
like no fun and is always like bossing
me around and then here's the Uber crazy
one you know what I mean that's kind of
hot but also like insane you know what I
mean so it's it just seemed like it was
just two sides of that coin so that's
kind of how it came across but you know
that said like the main care character
Steve uh he was no prize either
um and at times like as The Story Goes
On was actually straight up awful like
you find out some [__] about him later
but uh you know so I guess it all like
evens out so while they're on this
week-long holiday uh penny is kind of
planning out their vacation itinerary oh
we got to see this that and the other
thing which like I said you're in
Barcelona you might as well like see the
sights and stuff but Steve is just kind
of like whatever and he's not even
really listening to her most of the time
so while all of that is going on uh a
very strange series of events begins to
unfold
so while they're in the hotel restaurant
like not too long after arriving in
Barcelona Steve actually swears that he
sees his ex-girlfriend Annabelle sitting
at the bar
weird thing though is that sometimes it
definitely looks like her and like moves
like her and everything like that but
then a minute later like he looks back
and it doesn't really look like her
anymore and Steve is wondering how the
[__] did I think that it was her in the
first place so he's a little bit freaked
out by this uh as you might imagine
because Annabelle as it turns out uh was
a certifiable nutcase uh he dated her
years before I believe it was 10 years
before and they were together a while
but all his friends like hated her guts
and was like oh my God you got to get
rid of her uh they all just thought she
was a complete lunatic
now eventually like Steve kind of
gathered up enough intestinal fortitude
to dump her ass and he hasn't really
seen her or thought of her since then or
so you're led to believe at first uh
some complications in that regard are
introduced later on in the story so
Steve actually cannot imagine like why
Annabelle would be in Barcelona of all
places
um if indeed this woman is her which
he's never entirely sure about so if it
is her like is it just a coincidence
that she just happened there or is she
stalking him or is there something even
more bizarre going on
so like he goes to the restaurant like
every time he's in the hotel he sees her
sitting at the bar like all the time but
it's driving him crazy because sometimes
he swears it's her and then other times
he's like how the [__] could I think
it's clearly not her you know it doesn't
even look like her now it also turns out
that Steve and Penny are staying in room
and this mystery woman that he keeps
seeing is right next door in the titular
room 119. now Steve starts hearing like
some weird ass noises coming from the
room next door like scratching at the
walls and
um like kind of ragged breathing and
sounds like somebody's like thumping
around in there and he actually gets
kind of worried so he goes over there to
see what's going on and the woman
um you know answers the door and it's
clearly not Annabelle now but still sort
of like reminiscent of her but she acts
like nothing's wrong even though he
heard like all this [__] up [__] like
literally like a second ago there's also
the small matter of this light in the
hallway like outside of room 119 and
it's just like constantly flickering so
you know that should give you a hint of
where the direction of this is kind of
going in so Steve is pretty wigged out
by this whole entire situation
um and that leads him to be even more
checked out from Penny than he was
previously uh and since he doesn't tell
Penny at first like what's causing him
to be so distracted and you know cranky
penny is getting a little bit annoyed at
the way he's behaving um you know
understandably so
now roughly about a third of the way
through the story maybe sooner I can't
really remember something really drastic
happens involving this woman in room 119
which I won't spoil
but it's so [__] up that Stephen Penny
are just like well our whole entire
holiday is gonna be ruined now because
of this so you try to get like past the
trauma and Salvage what's left of their
time in Barcelona but shortly after this
horrific incident occurs
Steve starts to become convinced that
another woman who actually works at the
hotel who is a Spanish bartender whose
name is um estea I think or Estella he
starts to believe that she is actually
Annabelle even though Annabelle is
obviously English not Spanish and a
little bit older than this bartender
woman is now at this point Steve has
finally told Penny like what the
situation is like what is going on but
of course you know she just thinks he's
losing his marbles he does kind of like
think that too but you know what I mean
it's it's kind of that kind of thing she
thinks though that he's having some kind
of like weird like obsessive and like
super delayed reaction to like this
really bad breakup that he had with
Annabelle like a decade before so that's
what she thinks is going on and he kind
of goes back and forth on it because
he's not really sure what's going on
either separately though
um they're both kind of curious enough
to like so Stephen Penny each decide
they're going to do some investigation
into this Annabelle thing so to that end
they both separately like I said without
telling the other contact uh Steve's
friend Jack who's back in England who
knew Annabelle like back in the day and
he's like they want to figure out like
what happened to Annabelle like after
the breakup like where'd she go is it
possible she might be in Barcelona with
ill intent uh you know they just want to
figure out like Where She Went where
she's living now [__] like that
now long story short there are
definitely some Supernatural Shenanigans
afoot and that's not really a spoiler
because the word ghost is right there in
the title it's not a misnomer
but the story isn't quite as
straightforward as it might seem like At
first blush there are some interesting
twists and turns you know as it kind of
winds its way toward the conclusion
I will so say though that one thing in
the story that I found like kind of
frustrating was that you the reader will
figure out what's going on a long time
before Stephen Penny figure it out
um and while that admittedly happens in
a lot of stories and is actually a
pretty effective method for building
tension when it's done right here it
just seemed like the pair of them
particularly Steve were just like
complete idiots for like not figuring
out what was very obviously going on
like right in front of their faces like
yes what was going on involved the
Paranormal so it was you know ipso facto
like unbelievable so there's going to be
a bar to clear there obviously but as
the story went on it was so very clearly
spelled out in Universe what you know
that the situation was entirely
Supernatural and what was probably going
on but Steve was still going through all
these really absurd like mental
contortions you know in order to deny
the possibility that what was happening
could actually be really happening and
then after a certain point it was he was
just getting so much like that that I
just wanted to like slap him in the
mouth and being like duh it's like it's
obvious what's going on yes I know it's
unbelievable but come on get on the
[__] clue bus type of thing also
um in the third Act of the book we
actually do get some flashbacks like
where they kind of go into Steven
Annabelle's relationship like what
happened there and we also get like
numerous scenes from Annabelle's point
of view
so uh we also find out what you know
through all of that um that Steve is
even more of a [__] than he had
previously appeared and like I said he
wasn't super likable from the from the
get-go now for a while I thought that
the author was setting all this up to
make Annabelle seem more sympathetic or
hint that we were actually given a
mistaken impression of her because of
Steve's biased portrayal because we
don't we don't get introduced to
Annabelle until like later on in the
story we only know about Annabelle like
from other people like talking about
what a [__] nut she was so it's like
I was kind of interested to see it's
like oh is it going to be like a thing
where you know everyone's perception of
her was incorrect or something like that
but that doesn't really happen like
Annabelle when you meet her yeah she had
issues and you could actually kind of
have a smidge of empathy for her like in
that regard but
you know when you get to know her she
turns out to be like such an
over-the-top insane narcissistic douche
that kind of any good will that you
might have had built up for her like you
know that was engendered by Steve's like
shitty treatment of her previously was
kind of just thrown right out the window
you know what I mean so I don't know if
Amy cross was like trying to build up
sympathy for Annabelle because it's like
it seemed like she was kind of trying to
do that but it just didn't really get
there you know what I mean
um so you know as I said nobody in this
was really all that likable like none of
the three main characters and even Penny
who was you know the most innocent she
was just kind of like an innocent
bystander and so you know consequently
the least dickish of the three main
characters
um even she started to get on my nerves
pretty much immediately so as I
mentioned I had kind of like an
ambivalent like love-hate relationship
with this book like as I was reading it
on the one hand the mystery was really
intriguing and it got me hooked like
right from the first page I was like ooh
because I was trying to figure out oh
man like is Annabelle really there in
Barcelona like is she stalking him is
Steve is Steve suffering from like
delusions is something more complicated
going on so it was I was like really
into it you know I was on board on the
other hand though
the characters were all pretty grating
uh especially Steve and honestly I found
myself not really caring if something
bad happened to him
um and at times even kind of hoping like
he'd get [__] smacked around some
because he was just like because he was
like so annoying and I didn't really
care if anything happened bad happened
to Penny either and I didn't get a sense
of them like being in love with each
other as a couple like oh no like
Penny's in danger or she's like oh no
Steve's in danger like I didn't really I
was like why do these two like each
other I don't really I didn't really get
it so because I was like I don't like
either one of them but you know what I
mean I didn't get a sense of them as
like a couple you know what I'm saying
um I kind of feel like maybe if Steve
had been like more of a good guy or at
least like a more interesting guy I
think I would have been more maybe
emotionally evolved in his fate and
maybe like feared more for his safety as
like [__] started to hit the fan like as
the story went on
um alternately I kind of thought this
might have been a good idea too
um the story could have left the
characters as they were just like being
[__] or whatever but then played
with a sort of and I thought it was
going in this direction direction but it
didn't really but I thought it was going
to play with a little sort of a like a
he said she said narrative where Steve
perceived Annabelle and their former
relationship one way but then it turned
out that it wasn't really like that like
he had a delusional or he had like a
skewed
um view of it and I thought that would
have been a really good angle like to
explore but it didn't really do that
like to any great degree even though I
thought that it was kind of like going
in that direction so I mean all that
said though I actually still really did
enjoy this book quite a bit like I said
I don't really know why because like the
characters got on my nerves so much but
then I was like I just couldn't stop
reading it it was just like really
really weird it was it was just a weird
thing I don't remember ever having this
kind of like uh this kind of experience
reading something like this before
um so yeah so I really did enjoy it like
despite all my kavaching about it and I
did get really invested in where the
mystery was going so plot wise obviously
it really struck a chord and like kept
me on board with it I just wish that the
characters had been like a bit more
dynamic or a bit more appealing so I
could have really gotten maybe more
emotionally attached to the people in
the story rather than just the puzzle
like at this because I really did like
the kind of unspooling puzzle at the
center of the plot but it was just like
the people that were kind of like
annoying me like the whole time now this
book I will say does have a lot of
positive reviews on Goodreads I think
it's at 3.62 or you know 3.82 or
something like that so that means that
most readers clearly didn't have the
same issues that I did with it so I
would still like not hesitate to
recommend it to anybody who's it who's
into ghost stories but ghost stories
that have like a sort of unusual twist
to them because this is it has some
elements of like a classic ghost story
but it also like plays with those
elements so it's you don't really know
where it's gonna go initially which I
actually actually like really liked
about like once you figure it out at the
end like in the third act yeah you
figured it all out and then it just kind
of you know blows up from there but it's
like for a while you're just kind of
like oh well there's several directions
this could go you know what I mean
you're not really sure if like is it a
ghost is it traditional ghost is it like
something else going on is somebody
delusional so I I like that it kind of
had that ambivalence going for a while
but yeah if you like that kind of thing
that I would recommend it but and like I
said I
enjoyed it even though I think the
characters were the main thing that let
it down for me but yet it's still I
still felt compelled to like read it all
the time and finish it I read it
actually like really really quickly so
you know take of that which you will I
know it's like a weird thing and like I
said it was a weird experience for me
reading it but you know so that will do
it for this tomes of Terror book review
hope you guys enjoyed it please remember
to like And subscribe if you haven't
already and I'll see you guys again on
the next one bye